so tell me tell me this works now
because now starting to think that Willy
Wonka may be actually the perfect
computer analogy okay because
well the suspense is terrible he's gonna
be pissed I hope in life hi I'm Devin
I'm Spencer it's kind of funny Ali when
it's all laid out right here you see
just how simple at all the actual
construction of it is yeah what's the
order that you'll be assembling it in
power supply comes first then the
motherboard because can't really put
much else in until you get the
motherboard out then processor Ram
heatsink dries when you buy each part
like is there ever any times when
additional parts you may need are
missing if you plan everything ahead
usually not the only times I've had that
not be the case is if you decide to do
something special the Northbridge is
what actually connects everything
together the Northbridge is like the
central system when you buy a
motherboard you're buying that
Northbridge it's allows a certain amount
of bandwidth allows you to have certain
features it allows you to have USB 3.0
or not
I'll see you open this up with a katana
what the heck is this let the board
drive this case doesn't have one I'm so
lonely
I think the Western Digital I'll have an
estimated storage space to never be
lonely again a lot of what a computer is
I like to use a water analogy there's
pumps there's storage tanks there's the
whole system the pipes and everything
that kind of go along with that water is
like data data can only be accessed so
fast that's our reservoir we can't
necessarily do much with that
information without any other tools a
pressure system needs to be created and
that is our processor however you can't
put the water directly into the pump
needs to go to a quick storage tank and
that's the RAM in this case your
motherboard determines the size of the
pipes how much data you can let flow in
certain directions how big of a storage
tank or how much RAM you can put inside
the system and that's that's really the
biggest way I like to think about it
reservoir pressure tank processor
pressure tank or reservoir okay okay so
got that above the ramp actually really
quick can you find the manual
I need that real quick yes a lot of
motherboards do things a little slightly
differently we have quad channel RAM
and quad-channel ram needs to be put in
the motherboard in a specific way for
you to take advantage of the budget
they're saying to put it on the lighter
color ones that's exactly what we're
doing
pressure tanks are where you keep high
amounts of data that can move very fast
that's what Ram is random access memory
it allows you to take data put it into
the processor turn it and send it back
and then save it onto a hard drive
biggest trouble right now is having RAM
lose all of its information the second
you turn off the computer what's going
to put the heat sink in so what you do
to prepare yourself really lose a lot of
just taking apart my old computer and
just seeing like everything wet and you
see it like a Starbuck care that you
took art yeah which way to blow the air
have you given that any thought with
your PC builds hmm Origin PC says it's
best to suck air from outside into the
PC and then blow it all off the back a
GPU is a computer in itself in order to
be able to live render a full CG
environment everything is calculated
right then in that moment that means
that not only is like this system beefed
up but a large portion of that is
actually in this alternative house your
graphics house you only have a certain
amount space on your property to build
houses you can always have a second
property built somewhere else and it's
just completely huge building that's
dedicated to doing graphics processing
you could send your stuff over there
with a big pipe and have it sent back
and that's why I love in vidya Vidya has
been one of the best companies I've seen
out there in the market when you load up
a game you're taking it from the
reservoir you're having to send it into
a pressure tank in this case the
pressure tank is our RAM so we can
utilize it you open up the game it loads
the level when it's loaded level you're
actually taking the information from
your hard drive putting in the RAM
allowing the game to use now once the
game actually starts once you start
actually moving and doing stuff that's
when the processor comes into effect
it's locating that information that we
put inside of the storage tank and
pressurizing it to send it out to our
graphics card to render everything send
data from what monster are you having
how far are they where are they heading
with their vectors and doing a lot of
math to do that now the thing is once
you make progress once you hit a
checkpoint that information is sent back
to the RAM and that then is sent back to
the reservoir that's why sometimes you
can get file let's cry
because it was in the RAM and his trying
right to the hard drive but the computer
was cut in the middle of that process
and now you only have half file it does
go both ways you know you do you do
processing of that information you get
your results back and then you have to
store those results so for later use
what's the coolest thing that you know
Spencer's made amen
there are two things that like will
always stick out of my mind and one is a
Tesla coil spencer mate and he's a you
know just made it and just flips it a
line I'm like okay that's and then the
other thing is I mean Spencer was
freshman in high school he took two TVs
started creative pourcel between them
which then ignited the wasn't the oxygen
early created for it it's a it would
crave plasma there you create plasma in
the air you night at the air as a
freshman in high school who does that
because like that's something you don't
see coming the more layman's like like
myself thinking bull iguana actually
works exactly the same way as a computer
reservoir your chocolate River which is
your hard drive your all your data yeah
all your data try that's your new it
chocolate is delicious Dan and then you
have your two which is your RAM which is
actually what gets all the data movie
all your chocolate moving into
marshmallows in five seconds possible my
dear lady that's absurd unthinkable why
you because that pipe doesn't go to the
marshmallow room goes to the fudge room
from there it goes into a room that we
don't know about that has all the Oompa
Loompas and all them pulling levers
exactly do buddy do
but like the main one that's in charge
of it who's your North Bridge that's
unpolluted s conductor he's like yes
open up this tube like this one he's
actually controlling all of it or she no
no I won't hold you responsible off to
the side there's one part of the data
that's being siphoned off to another
Factory which is then being hardened
which is your graphics processing unit
like they're they're taking it they're
turning that liquid into a solid that
hard part gets sent off to an upward
stream which is your monitor in Willy
Wonka when they had that one candy that
appeared through the TV like I think I
was like taste division or some like
yeah and so they reach in they just take
the candy off so that's how your monitor
works then because that that marker is
not giving back to the system all that
liquid chocolate and stuff like that
some of it will be sent back to the
processing unit would be reduced back
into the river because like let's say
like there's a certain taste of
chocolate that they really like and so
it's being sent back in there that way
it slowly starts to integrate back with
the other chocolate it updates that
chocolate I'm really walking as a
computer but that's just the beginning
we have to get on there to get on we
have so much time and so little to do
strike that reverse it
thanks Obama so you got your hard drive
which is your River
you got your RAM which is the tooth you
should open your mouth a little wider
when you speak